dos esferas idénticas se liberan de un
dispositivo en el tiempo de igual a cero
a la misma altura h como se muestra en
la figura de arriba la esfera
no tiene velocidad inicial y cae al
suelo a la esfera b se le da a una
velocidad horizontal inicial de magnitud
de cero y viaja a una distancia
horizontal de antes de tocar el suelo
las esferas tocan el suelo al mismo
tiempo df aún cuando la esfera be ha
recorrido una mayor distancia antes de
tocar el suelo la resistencia al aire es
insignificante los puntos de abajo
representan las esferas ahí ve dibuja un
diagrama de cuerpo libre mostrando y
etiquetando las fuerzas no los
componentes ejercidas en cada esfera en
el tiempo de efe entre 2
aquí tenemos nuestras esferas y cuando
esta cosa se libera la esfera cae
directamente y la esfera ve en la
dirección vertical caer a la misma
distancia pero en la dirección
horizontal tiene cierta velocidad que
hará que se desplace y toque
a una distancia de hacia la derecha
cuando toque el suelo este suv
efe y aquí arriba justo antes de que se
liberen las esferas tenemos de igual a
cero aquí abajo t es igual a sub
efe nos piden un diagrama de cuerpo
libre ente igual a de sube efe entre 2
que es cuando ambas esferas se
encuentran en el aire cuando ambas
esferas se encuentran en el aire la
única fuerza que está actuando en ambas
es la fuerza de gravedad y ya que las
esferas son idénticas la fuerza de
gravedad también será idéntica vamos a
dibujarlas aquí está la fuerza de
gravedad en la esfera y aquí está la
fuerza de gravedad en la esfera ve aquí
escribimos fuerza
gravedad
y podemos decir que su magnitud es f
surge si queremos podemos etiquetar las
como la masa m por el campo
gravitacional g y esto es todo a la
mitad de la caída la única fuerza que
está actuando es la fuerza de gravedad
la resistencia al aire es insignificante
y la fuerza de gravedad en ambas esferas
va a ser la misma ya que ambas tienen la
misma masa ahora veamos el inciso b en
los ejes coordenadas de abajo dibuja y
etiqueta una gráfica del componente
horizontal de la velocidad de la esfera
y de la esfera ve como función del
tiempo voy a graficar primero la esfera
a ya que es ya que es bastante directo
la esfera así recuerdan aquí arriba la
esfera no tiene velocidad horizontal
solo se va a ir moviendo y acelerando en
la dirección vertical hacia abajo por lo
que la esfera
no tiene componente horizontal de la
velocidad por lo que dibujaré una línea
así
sobre el eje en el valor cero durante
todo el tiempo porque no tiene
componente horizontal ahora con la
esfera ve que esto va a ser un poco más
interesante nos dice que es su velocidad
inicial horizontal es be subíndice cero
o mejor dicho la magnitud de su
velocidad inicial horizontal es b
subíndice cero ya que la resistencia al
aire es insignificante va a continuar
moviéndose hacia la derecha con una
magnitud de b subíndice cero hasta que
toque el suelo por lo que la esfera ve
de aquí voy a elegir cuál quiero que sea
b sub cero que es la magnitud de su
velocidad horizontal por lo que la
esfera b estará en esta velocidad hasta
el tiempo final que vamos a decir está
aquí te sube efe aquí está de igual a
cero y aquí te es igual a te sube efe
durante todo el tiempo que la esfera
esté en el aire
el componente horizontal de su velocidad
será constante nada lo va a disminuir ya
que la resistencia al aire es
insignificante
justo cuando toca el suelo la fuerza que
detiene a la esfera es esencialmente la
fuerza de fricción y esto hace que el
componente horizontal de la velocidad
llegue muy rápidamente a cero
ahora resolvamos el inciso c aunque
antes podríamos etiquetar esto si
quisiéramos esto es la esfera b y esto
es la esfera a y pueden quitar el resto
de la línea de la esfera a porque ya no
se va a mover después del tiempo t efe
escribe en un párrafo una respuesta
clara y coherente para explicar por qué
las esferas alcanzan el suelo al mismo
tiempo aún cuando recorren distancias
diferentes incluye referencias a tus
respuestas de los incisos a y ve muy
bien pensemos en esto para así escribir
un párrafo claro y coherente desde te
igual a cero desde te igual a cero
hasta
igual efe la única fuerza
la única fuerza que actúa
la única fuerza que actúa en las esferas
la fuerza de gravedad
es la fuerza de gravedad con dirección
hacia abajo
con dirección hacia abajo
/ igual a 0
gente igual a cero la magnitud la
magnitud
de ambas velocidades
la magnitud de ambas velocidades en la
dirección vertical
en la dirección vertical es cero
después de ti igual a cero
después de ti igual a cero las esferas
se aceleran
con la misma proporción
las esferas se aceleran con la misma
proporción
por lo que
los componentes verticales por lo que
los componentes verticales
de sus velocidades
de sus velocidades siempre son iguales
siempre son iguales
recorren la misma distancia vertical
y recorren la misma distancia vertical
por lo que llegan al suelo al mismo
tiempo permítanme leer esto de nuevo
para asegurarme de que tenga sentido
desde este igual a 0 hasta te iguala te
sube efe la única fuerza que actúa en
las esferas es la fuerza de gravedad con
dirección hacia abajo entre igual a cero
la magnitud de ambas velocidades en la
dirección vertical es cero después de t
igual a cero las esferas se aceleran con
la misma proporción por lo que los
componentes verticales de sus
velocidades siempre son iguales y
recorren la misma distancia vertical
continuamos por lo que por lo que
llegan al suelo
por lo que llegan al suelo al mismo
tiempo
al mismo tiempo las esferas tienen
diferente velocidad horizontal pero esto
no afecta al tiempo ni a la velocidad ni
a la distancia en la dirección vertical
escribimos tienen
diferentes
velocidades tienen diferentes
velocidades horizontales
horizontales
pero eso no afecta
el tiempo en el que las esferas
el tiempo
el que en el que las esferas
recorren la misma distancia vertical
recorren la misma distancia vertical y
ustedes podrían escribir más al respecto
como por ejemplo el que si se suma en
los componentes de dichas velocidades la
esfera bet tendrá una mayor velocidad
que la esfera a porque sumamos el
componente vertical y horizontal de la
velocidad por lo que la esfera be cubre
una mayor distancia en el espacio en la
misma cantidad de tiempo que la esfera
pero si pensamos solamente en la
dirección vertical ambas esferas
recorrerán la misma cantidad de
distancia en la misma cantidad de tiempo
así que en la dirección vertical tienen
la misma velocidad ambas comenzaron con
una velocidad vertical de ser